what I want to do in this video is give
an overview of how money is created in
most market-based economies and even a
little bit of a discussion of what
really is money and we can go into much
more depth in future videos and I think
in many videos I already have gotten to
a much more technical depth in most
market-based economies right now there
is a central bank which is essentially
the the actor they do many things they
often will be a regulatory agency as
well but their main role is to be to
have the right to print money and to put
that money into circulation so and I'll
rely heavily on the model of the US and
that central bank that central bank and
that's hard to read the central bank the
central bank in some countries is
formally part of the government in other
countries it's pseudo independent in the
u.s. it's more of the pseudo independent
flavor of a central bank although
obviously closely closely connected with
the government the US Federal Reserve a
lot of the leaders are pointed appointed
by the government it's excess profits go
back to the government and so obviously
that has very close ties to the
government but when the central bank
decides to print money it literally can
just create it it could literally print
physical money or it can create
electronic money which has the same
exact effect so let's say the central
bank it goes out there and it goes out
there and it prints it prints three and
we'll just focus on the physical right
now it's a little bit easier to
conceptualize and it just goes out there
and it prints three physical dollar
bills now it has to figure out how does
it get it into circulation how does it
get it into the economy and it does not
just put it into a helicopter and drop
it from that helicopter sometimes in
certain circumstances it can lend this
directly it can lend this directly to
banks certain types of Bank member banks
but the typical way that this enter
circulation is that the central bank
will use this newly created money this
newly created reserves I should say to
go out into the open market and buy
securities and they typically buy very
safe securities typically government
debt so they will go out there and they
will put this into circulation
they will put this into circulation and
in exchange they are buying they are
buying securities from the open market
so then these securities from the open
market will go to the central bank so
these are securities or maybe we could
call them bonds and once they do that
then whoever had these before whoever
was the owner of these securities before
they just sold them now they have these
dollar bills and they will they could
either directly spend those dollar bills
or they could deposit those dollar bills
in the bank if they spend the dollar
bills and whoever they gave those dollar
bills to at some point would want to
deposit in a bank so some way by buying
these buying these securities someone
now has these dollar bills and they will
deposit them in a private bank so let's
draw that so right over here
right over here is a private bank and
now it has the dollar bills it has these
reserves now it has the reserves now
that's not the end of the story this
money can now be lent and this is key
because this is what's what's typical in
in most market economies where they have
fractional reserve lending so fractional
fractional reserve lending which is a
bit a bit strange because you are
telling the person who just deposited
this money right here that you can go at
any time and you can take this money out
we've got this money for you you can
trust us you don't have to be paranoid
about what's going on with this money
but the reality is is that this Bank is
allowed to keep only a fraction of these
reserves and lend the rest of it out to
lend the rest of it out in order for the
system to not be super fragile the
central bank then also insures these
banks but we'll talk about that into
more depth but here I just want to show
you how the money is created in this
fractional reserve lending system so
this Bank right over here says we'll
have to keep a little bit of these
reserves in case that guy comes the
probability of all of my all of them all
of my customers coming on the same day
and asking for all of their money is low
I just have to keep a little bit for
whoever does come and then the rest of
it I can lend out even though I promised
everyone that all of their money is
available and so they lend it out to
whoever
needs to borrow that money who looks
like a decent risk and those people
might not spend it immediately and so
they would deposit it into a bank or
they might spend that money immediately
they buy a factory or they buy a car or
they do something with it and whoever
they bought that new thing from those
people now have the money and they will
deposit into a bank and so this newly
lent money will then end up in perhaps
another Bank it could even be the same
Bank so that will also end up also end
up in in a bank right over here and now
this Bank it can also only keep a
fraction of the reserves and lend out
the rest and for simplicity in most
banking systems they only have to keep
ten on the order of about 10 percent of
the reserves in house and the rest they
can lend out but over here I'm keeping
much larger reserves just for the sake
of making it easy to draw this diagram
so this Bank right over here maybe it
decides to keep this dollar bill and it
could lend to this one right over here
out and once again when it lends that
dollar bill it will end up somehow the
person they lend it to might keep it in
a bank temporarily or they might
immediately buy something and when they
buy something it will eventually end up
in a bank as a person they bought
something from will deposit that money
and so it could end up in another bank
it could end up in another Bank and now
this is interesting and in future videos
we'll go into more of the math of
exactly how much money is being created
and it's an interesting mathematical
interesting mathematical problem
actually it's a sum of an infinite
series and all of that and you can look
up look that up if you're interested in
those ideas but the basic idea here is
even though the central bank printed
three units of base money
three dollars right over here there's a
lot more money in the system you have
this guy who made this deposit thinks he
has three dollars this person had thinks
af2 this person thinks they have one so
just in this example over here we have
one two three four five six dollars so
just right over here we have six dollars
in this system six dollars and you might
say well is this really money you know
this is deposited this guy thinks he has
it but he's not using it if he had to
use it he would have to withdraw it and
then the bank wouldn't be able to do
this and this is where checking accounts
are really important I'm assuming that
these were on demand checking accounts
so this guy the reason why he's not
going to
draw this money is he can still use it
as money by writing checks so if this
guy let's say this is all the money that
he has and he decides that he really
needs to buy an apple and that Apple
costs $1 and that Apple costs $1 so this
is my drawing of an apple right over
here he does not have to walk withdraw
this dollar
out of the bank he can write a check so
right now he has claims to the to all
three of these dollars he can write a
check to the Apple vendor so one dollar
one dollar here you know he writes a
check gives it to the Apple vendor and
now he'll get the Apple so this check is
acting as money and now the Apple vendor
will have the rights to one of these
dollars right over here and now the
Apple vendor could write a check so this
dollar never has to leave the banking
system but because of checks is
essentially enabling this check writing
it's enabling these tractions
transactions to occur so it's still
enabling either you can view it as it's
it's still acting in some forms of money
because the rights to it can change even
though it's sitting out in here and it's
been lent or you could say that it's
enabling the writing of checks that are
acting as some form of money and the
whole reason I want to do this I'm going
through this exercise to show you that
the amount of money in circulation isn't
really in the central banks or not
directly into central banks control they
can definitely decide hey I'm going to
print money buy securities put it into
circulation or if they want to take
money out of circulation they can decide
to sell these securities and then when
they sell the securities maybe this guy
will buy them those dollars will go back
to the central bank and maybe they could
put it out of commission but you have
this whole effect right over here if you
have more lending occurring if the banks
are feeling very confident then more of
this will happen you will get more of
this the multiplier effect of this
lending and if less lending is happening
then you could potentially see all of
this contract